we've been talking about what might
donald trump do on his way
out of office will he just retreat to
one of his resorts
at thanksgiving or at christmas and
never come back to washington dc
will he do anything about the raging
coronavirus pandemic
the one thing we did not necessarily
think of was would trump
bomb somebody on the way out of office
would trump attack another country
and indeed last week donald trump was
looking at hey maybe i will bomb
iran and i will talk to you about this
in a moment this reminds me of the
conversation we've had over the last
four years
which thankfully are coming to an end
very very soon about
yes trump is a lazy piece of whatever
and he golfs more than anyone and he
watches tv all day and all this stuff
but at the same time when donald trump
does something it's usually bad
so are we better off with donald trump
doing nothing and this is sort of an
example of that as recently as last
thursday donald trump went to advisers
and said
what options do i have for bombing
iran's
main nuclear site in the next few weeks
four days ago donald trump was
considering bombing iran in his
remaining weeks in office now
why was donald trump asking about this
well because of a situation
of his own creation international
inspectors have reported an increase
in the nuclear material stockpile in
iran
and reportedly everybody in the room
with trump
which is shocking because there were
some pretty horrible people in the room
like mike pence
reportedly everybody in the room told
donald trump this was a bad idea vice
president mike pence was in the room
uh horrible depraved secretary of state
mike pompeo was in the room
um christopher c miller the acting
defense secretary was in the room
general mark milley chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff was in the room
and they all said
even yes even mike pence who's out of
his mind
this might cause a bigger conflict this
isn't a bad idea
this might end up with you leaving
office in the middle of an absolute mess
that
your name will be attached to and they
reportedly discussed
options of a missile attack or a
cyber attack and when the meeting was
over officials
reportedly felt they had talked trump
out of the missile attack idea
at least for the time being but donald
trump continues to be
interested in some kind of attack on
iran
maybe cyber it's incredible what baron
is doing with computers these days that
would be one
one aspect of it maybe attacking iranian
allies
in iraq as an example trump's still
interested in this now
the position of trumpists on this iran
issue and trump considering bombing them
is completely incoherent because they
are
choosing to say only look iran is
developing
nuclear material and that's bad and so
we should go after them but to really
understand this you need to go back to
the basics on the issue now i want to
i don't know that i need to do this but
because it's been a while since we
talked about iran i feel like i should
issue a disclaimer of sorts
i am no iran apologist and in fact
um if if you know i don't think uh
iran should have a nuclear weapon we can
talk more broadly about
whether anybody should but today i don't
think iran should have a nuclear weapon
who am i to say it right but i don't
think they should have one
um i i don't find iran particularly
trustworthy
etc if you've been watching my show you
know i am no defender of the iranian
regime
but this situation is trump's fault
iran is acting rationally given the
circumstances now you might be saying
how
trump's how could it be trump's fault
that iran has nuclear material
remember that we had a deal with iran
the
iran nuclear deal forged during the
obama administration
while we were in the deal iran allowed
all of the inspections that they were
committed to allowing as part of the
deal
there was no evidence from inspectors
that they were violating the deal
this doesn't mean anything about
trusting
iran more broadly all it means is
there was a deal iran stuck to its
end of the bargain based on the
inspections that were taking place
which they allowed as part of the deal
donald trump comes into office
and just gets out of the deal he cancels
it he he voids the deal
this is one of the worst things you can
do in geopolitics in foreign policy
which is without anybody having done
anything wrong
you come in and just because you don't
like your predecessor in this case trump
doesn't like barack obama you get out of
the deal you cancel a deal your
predecessor made for
domestic political reasons that have
nothing to do with whether the parties
stuck to the deal this immediately
destroys
the credibility of the united states as
a negotiating partner
now and in the future iran did
what they were committed to doing and
trump came in and said we're voiding the
deal
now at the time i and many others said
you know
with without defending iran this is now
inviting iran to start stockpiling
nuclear material and advancing their
research
why wouldn't iran do that if you
understand geopolitics and history you
know that when countries give up their
nuclear programs
things often don't go that well for them
in the following years
and when you take away the incentive for
an iran not to do it
they would logically start doing it
again
either to have something to negotiate
with in the future to be able to say
okay here's something we would be
willing to stop
in order to get things geopolitically or
because they just
believed they would be better off having
a nuclear program so
the expectation of anybody who
understood what was going on was when
trump canceled the deal
that iran would start accumulating
material and resume its nuclear program
why the hell wouldn't they do it
so that happens to some degree and now
trump says well maybe i should bomb them
they're not allowed to do that well we
had a deal they were sticking to
which you cancelled for no reason
whatsoever and so
to understand this you have to
understand that it is a
problem that donald trump precipitated
and the question becomes now with where
were 10 weeks to go in the trump
presidency
now what well hopefully donald trump
will hold off on any
action any attack on iran hopefully when
joe biden
is sworn in he can put some kind of a
deal back together with iran but the
problem
as we already know is that iran will be
skeptical of a future deal
and they are right to be skeptical
because any deal they make
might just be voided by the following
president they could spend years
adhering to the deal
giving up what they would see as
development of nuclear
that that would give them leverage in
future negotiations
and they do it all to see the next
republican president come in and say i
don't like joe biden's deal i'm going to
get the hell out of it so
if i were iran i would be skeptical
based on how donald trump has behaved
i hate to turn them into the right
ones to be skeptical because we also
have every right to be skeptical and
careful when we're dealing with iran
but because of what donald trump has
done
iran has every right to be skeptical of
the united states and if i were them
i absolutely would be so total disaster
and trump may still get another bombing
done
before he ultimately leaves office let's
hope it doesn't happen
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by caltech
scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online from countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20 percent off when you use
the coupon code
pacman and just a quick disclaimer i'm
required
to give these products contain nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical